من عمان اللواء فايز الدوير الخبير
العسكري
والاستراتيجيه وابدا من هذا التطور لكن
لدينا التطورات اخرى فايز تحتاج الى
مناقشه ما معنى اسقاط اوكرانيا لهذا
الصاروخ
يعني هذا جاء رد على التصريح الروسي
السابق بانها هذا الصاروخ والصاروخ صارمات
كلاهما لا يمكن اعتراضه والان جاء الخبر
باسقاط احد هذه الصواريخ وهذا امر متوقع
لماذا اسقط بصاروخ باك 3 عندما نعمل
مقارنه رياضيه ما بين الصاروخين نجد ان
صاروخ
الخنجر كانجال
يحتاج الى 27 دقيقه ثانيه
منذ لحظه اكتشافي لوصول الهدف وبينما
صاروخ باك 3 يحتاج تسع ثواني من لحظه
اكتشاء الاكتشاف الصاروخ القادم ليتم
اطلاقه اذا هنا نتحدث عن زمنين زمن
الفاعليه لصاروخ الباتريوت يكون متقدما
بحدود حسب سرعه الصاروخ
سبعه الى نعم وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن تطور
في الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني تطور واضح بعد
وصول هذه الصاروخ لانه تقنيا وريا يمكن
لفاك 3 يسقطه من التصريحات اللافته هو
تصريحات
قائد شركه ومقاتله فاجنر تصريحاته بالامس
ثم تصريحاته اليوم بالامس سباب ولعان
لوزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان بسبب نقص
الذخيره اليوم يطالب رسميا او يقول انه
سيطالب رسميا بتسليم باخموت من قواته الى
قوات قديروف لماذا قدروف لماذا ليس الجيش
ليس للجيش الروسي
هو في منافسه حاده مع الجيش الروسي وموضوع
الذخيره هي دعني اقول قمه جبل الجليد من
الخلافات ما بين قائد قوات فاجنر والمؤسس
العسكريه ووزاره الدفاع هو اختصرها بصياغه
فقط تبين مدى الحاجه ومدى محاوله تعجيم
الانتصارات التي تقوم بها مجموعه لكن كثير
من التقارير التي صدرت تتحدث عن خلافات
اعمق تتحدث عن مد النفوس داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه
خلافات حول
نظام التخصيص الموازنات
لموازره الحرب او نظام المكافات او ادماج
المقاتلين في نظام التعويضات او تحويل
قوات فاجنر الى جيش شعبي يعني الخلافات
كبيره جدا خاصه انه هو يسعى الى طموح شخصي
وقد الى على قوات العديد من الجنرالات
الروس الذين تم احالتهم على التقاعد
وبالتالي اصبح كانه قوه موازيه والان يشعر
ان الكرملين يسعى الى ابقاء التوازن ما
بين مراكز الثقل ما بين وزاره الدفاع
والجيش وما بين قوه باجنر ولا يستطيع
التخلي عن اي منهما هذا الوضع الجديد جعله
يتحدث لكن لماذا قوات
قد يروف ولانها قوات تقاتل بنفس الاليه
والمنهجيه ولا يريد لا يريد ان يعطي تحرير
حوالي 80% من باخموت الى الجيش ليكون في
عيد النصر اذا تحققت انه هو صاحب الفضل
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه من عمان شكرا لك